so is it the flavor that's legal or the
food it's gone full french man who takes
a bag of candy like this opens a candy
each half of it and puts the other half
of the candy back inside the candy bag
[Music]
I think you boys are doing it's gone
full French man so be drinking on the
job what's going on I just came back for
my honeymoon in France it was lovely and
for one part of the trip
ivy and I were lucky enough to stay at a
farm where they made a traditional
French delicacy known as foie gras
now this food is actually banned from
being produced in California and a few
other countries in the world
what is foie gras why is advanced the
name literally translates to fat liver
and usually it's a pate which is kind of
a meat paste I made from the fatty liver
of geese or ducks everyone's in the
office I think you dig it
now when you in store the fat we tend to
store it under our skin however birds
such as ducks or geese also store fat in
their liver and before they migrate they
gorge themselves on food causing these
fat deposits to build up for the long
journey the liver rich in fat is what
makes foie gras so tasty but in order to
produce it the physical process of
growing the fatty liver in the bird
needs to be triggered this is where the
controversy enters the picture because
they live in a farm these birds don't
migrate therefore they don't gorge
themselves in order to trigger the
growth of the fatty liver
they must be force-fed in the last few
weeks before they are slaughtered to
understand how the force-feeding is done
it's important to understand the
physiology of the birds geese and ducks
don't chew their food they don't have
teeth instead they swallow their food
whole and they store it in the sack and
the bottom of the thrill known as a crop
pulse' they don't breathe through their
throat a tube from their lungs actually
runs out and through their tongues so
following the physical process much like
how a duck swallows a fish hole a farmer
uses a tube deposit a portion of the
food in the bird's crop the abundance of
food triggers the liver to begin storing
fats and then the liver for foie gras is
created that's it I know that no one
here at corridor has ever tried this
before and because it's banned the crew
will never have the opportunity I wanted
to share this little experience of
French culinary history with them I
brought back walk her off in the farm
that I stayed at I want a surprise or no
one knows what this is maybe they'll
find it delicious
maybe they'll hate it we won't know
until they try it now how do we really
know you actually went to France
anytime I go on a trip I like to bring
back gifts for people little treats
things like that
sorry think of a good gift I could bring
everybody in the studio we have some
friends of the family that have a farm
in France and this is something that
they make I'd like you guys to taste it
it's a meat-based thing I personally
find it delicious the production of it
is banned in California yeah so this is
my gift to all of you guys first off a
little toast so is it the flavor that's
legal or the food the illegal flavors
fling up dance it's because there's a
bunch of rotten oranges here and then
someone someone someone who does this
who does this who who who takes a bag of
candy like this this is what I found
who takes a bag of candy like this opens
a candy eats half of it and puts the
other half of the candy back inside the
candy bag flavors Franks anyways here
here's the culprit tuba I threw it in
the garbage but I missed
and then more ants swarmed around it see
that I'm so confused like what world do
we live in when you're filming a food
segment for a YouTube channel and you
don't want to clean up the ants first
that are literally on the counter little
spices there's still more over here what
the world is nicko living in yeah all
you got to do is just wipe out the main
trail of them and no but like apparently
it's so important that even ants and it
can't get in the way of his boots what
if we just ate the ants I think the part
of the plan all right guys try a slice
is it meat butter
this kind of smells like dog food no
taste like meat butter let me wash it
down like this it's just weird to taste
meat without the meat texture that's
like a cow fell into the the butter
factories churning machine food smells
really good you kinda just wanna try it
this is like that no one ever thinks it
you don't have ad understand I've never
smelled dog food that I wanted to try I
don't think you guys know what fog rise
no I
you make it with the fat we blend it up
with spices and you get this
so it's meat with a ton of fat mixed
into it so it is meat butter aspect of
this isn't the the feeding of geese
until they're so they're liver is so fat
is that the unethical part here yes -
we've got Andrew couple and Richard Lynn
Burr and Rory so Hawk lie we've got
tailored unmarked pitch cube James
Bailey Brian and toes you can Richard's
black
- yes they help us out making videos and
if you're interested in helping us out -
you could go to patreon.com slash
corridor digital give us a buck or two
and we'd use it to make cool videos give
Nick some not gray hair and then we know
not to make music for our career today's
a good day it's Monday
I've got days left I usually keep my
phone on silent this week no it's on
loud and it's a - extra loud in case
Sarah calls me little baby Jesus baby
g-man it's gonna get real this week very
emotional actually it's like the moist
like it's like it is weird and it's
getting very real it's hitting me really
hard but there's other good news there's
over a hundred VFX shots in this anime
self-driving car video and about a third
of them are full CG shots cars 3d oh my
god there's so much work can I get all
the Priebus for this video done before
my baby is born right here two here and
two here and you never drive through did
you do all the animation way have you
already done the animation no I'm good
it's not that it's gonna be all straight
and then basically I'm gonna camp the
camera and we're just gonna place
anything like an angle like a really
harsh 45-degree game this is all steep
the hill is it's absurd you're not gonna
be real though I know but how scary is
that driving down that steep of a hill
let me rephrase not that it's not gonna
look real I worried that maybe it's
gonna be so extreme d'Arnaud
there are no roads in existence right
now there are like 45 degree angle 30 30
30 exists perfect super steep by the way
I know that's why it's gonna be super
scary I dig it I like it
oh my god I'm just like constantly
animating these cars they look so good
oh my god these shots dude yeah even the
animated the camera car in certain shots
as you can see here it's very important
that we get actually actual perspective
of the drivers so I actually went into
the scene and animated the camera
and yeah that's me so basically I had to
go into the scene here and actually get
the shots by myself that's me there
holy bonkers dude and that's a yes I did
it all I have I counted it up 37 Priebus
shots oh my god
37 doesn't seem like a lot but when you
packed 37 into about six days that's 37
shots across about like 20 files my mind
is like numb I got to drop them into the
sequence I got to clean it up I gotta
throw animate I got there's still a lot
of stuff I have to do what I did
easily is gonna take around a couple
like two or three weeks of work to
actually realize I'm building this stuff
and he's finishing I hand him the stone
and I hand him the blueprints and then
he takes the chisel out and the polish
and he turns it into the actual
beautiful shot things he's gonna be
adding he's probably gonna make some
camera tweaks here and there he's gonna
be sprucing up the environments a little
bit so there's streetlights and some
guard rails stuff like that he obviously
is gonna do the lighting HDR map that's
gonna set the scene lighting there's all
sorts of little things he's gonna do not
to mention make sure that all the car
materials are alright well basically
working so yeah put about yeah probably
50 somewhere between 50 and 60 hours
just into the praetor's think ren
finally finally understands everything
that's happening
so I was trying to think of like what I
could compare approaching fatherhood to
be like and I started realizing that
being a parent is kind of like Dungeons
& Dragons we imagine imagine this
imagine this I know how the world works
generally and I'm about to encounter a
new player in this world who has no idea
what the world is what the rules are so
yeah I mean I mean when he's born it's
it's gonna be it's gonna start the same
way as any D&D starts out like here is
28 teen Donald Trump is the president
and you wake up and find yourself in the
state of California what do you do next
and I'm just there to help shape the
world and explain things along the waves
when the kid asks about something I'm
there to explain it you know what I mean
like I'm I'm playing DM in this little
kids life and so that's really exciting
actually because I know I know how to do
that I'm like oh my god I got it
once I get over the whole like poop and
pee thing yeah yeah things it you're
afraid of happening things okay good
good question aside from all the
real-life physical stuff yeah assuming
it's after that oh man
I'm afraid of becoming a lame guy a lame
dad although Jake became a father and
then I think he almost got cooler after
that all his qualities suddenly got like
really sharp and refined you know his
personality is work ethic everything so
everyone so for everyone's been
constantly like get sleep while you can
huh have fun while you can yeah dude do
anything you're trying to do in your
life while you still can because it's
about to be over
it's the same thing with getting married
it's the same thing with making any
decision it's once again boys
D&D come on remember that remember that
like I'm already in the mindset like I
got it this would be great you know I'm
a little saddened but also really
relieved that I'm gonna be taking about
a month off here I'm probably gonna be
working from home gonna you know keep in
touch
probably swing by the studio every once
in a while so you'll see a check-in
you'll all walk in everyone
but I'm like hey how's it goin it's me
remember me i'll be--i'll have like a
gray beard that's me oh that was me when
I was younger
shall we take the Mario hats and put
them on and fill the video haha help me
master I'm very Master Chief shall be me
in like two weeks after I deal with all
the stress of having a kid if you don't
come in Monday that means baby Jesus
landed yeah
[Music]
three-two-one
you know can hold his breath for a long
time Tom Cruise and in the next seven
nicovideo we're gonna see if we can hold
our breath longer than he can it's gonna
be great the whole crews gonna go for it
I've been training so is Jake subscribe
if you're not oh no